four seconds order from these
programming
okay so I'm going to speak about quantum
algorithms for a second or the control
Grammy and
and we should begin by defining what
second-order Coons are and and how this
class of second all the corn programming
is intermediate between linear and semi
definite programs but it's still
distinct from both so the second-order
coins are also known as Lawrence cones
and let's begin with the definition of
the Lawrence cone so the n-dimensional
Dorian school is defined as a set of
vectors in RN where the size of the
first coordinate X naught is bigger than
the norm of all the other coordinates so
here's the picture from the baqia which
shows the Rollins cone for three
dimensions
me or try to adjust this lights a bit
so so this is a picture of n3 which is
the set of all points X Y Z so that Z
square is bigger than X plus y squared
and also let's look at l1 which is
simply all the positive points in R
which is simply R + so a second-order
cone program is an optimization problem
where the constraints of the form vector
X belongs to some Lawrence cone Alain
so let's give a formal definition of a
socb so so in the general form it's a
optimization problem of a product of
Lauren scones so I'll write the more
compact description shortly in the next
slide but let's see a more expanded
description so it's minimizing a linear
function where you can think of these
components as lying in different
tolerance cones so it's even transpose X
1 and C 2 transpose X 2 and so on and
then there are linear constraints on
spring mattresses AI which belong to our
M times n i4 INR and and the cony
constraints are that each X I belongs to
these Lawrence cones so so the two
important parameters characterizing the
size of this problem in terms of which
the running times would be given at the
rank and the dimension so so the rank of
the CP is a number of Lawrence country
constraints so it's a number of Lawrence
cones involved in in this problem
definition and the dimension is the sum
of the dimensions of all the vectors so
n is the sum of Ni and r is the number
of valence cones so the running times of
all algorithms would be given in terms
of RN and the duality gap or how close
you the solutions are to the optimal
so more compactly it can be written as
an optimization problem over the
productive Lawrence Coons and in this
form it he looked very similar to linear
and semi definite programs so here this
is standard form of the primal and dual
SOC P so this is what pain by
concatenating all the C's and the excess
of the last light so so now the problem
is to minimize C transpose X where ax is
equal to B and X belongs to L where L is
the product of all these Lawrence cones
and similarly one can write the dual and
one see is that it's formally very
similar to SDP or LP in in the standard
form so socb is generalizing the
program's first of all because as we saw
in the first slide l1 is the set of
positive real numbers so by adding
constraints in the Lord and spoon Alvin
we can replicate LP constraints and it
also generalize this convex QPS which
will it see in the next slide as we see
examples of problems that can be
formulated as SOC peas and the running
time of these algorithms as I said
before will be given in terms of NR and
the duality gap it
so one of the most important problems
that reduces to SOC B's is the support
vector machine problem in machine
learning so let me say what this problem
is and how it reduces to the SOC P
briefly
so the SVM Zard one of the most
important classification algorithms in
machine learning so the input to the SVM
is is a training set of vectors X I
which are the data points and the labels
Y I so the SVM is formulated as a convex
QP where the objective function is to
minimize this weight vector plus
regularization term and we have
constraints that each each Magnum
training set is being classified
properly so it's in other words W
transpose X is a good classifier for the
training set WI but yeah so so the
constraints are by i w transpose X I
plus B a bigger than one minus Z I so so
be imposing the constraint that all
these points are being separated by a
wide margin hyperplane so the zeta is a
penalizing how how much you violate the
constraints so so you have a Elven
regularization in terms of the zi and
this is the formulation of SPMS which is
the standard formulation used in machine
learning applications
so so now let's see quickly how to write
the quadratic constraint as linear
constraint over the Laurence cone so
that would show us how to represent the
SVM problem as SSEP so we introduce a
new vector T plus 1 T W and and impose
the constraint that it belongs to
Dorian's n plus 2 so this constraint
means that T plus 1 squared is bigger
than T squared plus W squared so when
you cancel out the quadratic terms
you're left with 2 T plus 1 bigger than
norm of W squared so now you can change
the objective function to two optimized
to minimize T instead of W Square and
the T plus 1 T W is a linear constraint
it's saying that X 2 minus X 1 is equal
to 1 so so this quadratic program has
been reduced to an SOC P which is wholly
constraints plus linear constraints
to be reduced it without losing much in
the dimension so we reduced it to an SCP
with BT Bilstein L enters two and and
zti which are supposed to be positive so
they are all in l1 and the rank is n
plus M plus 2 by M is the size of the
training set n is the dimension so
so convex quadratic programs can be seen
as one of the most important classes of
applications for the SOC t so now I can
state a main results so the main so the
best classical associate algorithm is
based on the interior point methods and
it's given by Bentall and Amir offski
and it has running time square root R
and Omega login of Epsilon
so Omega is the exponent for matrix
multiplication in practice we'll see
that it's it's it's more than you make
the exponents for these socb solvents so
so in this world P developer quantum
interior point method versus hippies and
the running time of this quantum IPM is
n 1 point 5 square root R plus some
other quantum specific factors which are
the condition number and the distance of
the intermediate solutions from the cone
boundary which I latest cap over Delta
squared times log 1 over Epsilon
and apart from the statistical result we
we we have to make better mental results
on random SVM instances so I'll define
what these random instances are later so
the so if empirically we find that the
quantum algorithm scales as order n to
the K where K belongs to two point five
six to two point six two with high
probability and the external SOC P
solvers skills as in three point three
one so so that can be seen as some
evidence of polynomial speed upon the
quadratic programs in SOC Peas in theory
the classical one is better so in theory
if you look at exponents of n it is
Omega is two point three seven in theory
okay so now I'll try to explain to you
why a SUSE peas are an important problem
in their own right like this delay
between linear and semi definite
programs and I love to talk a bit about
Jordan algebras which are used heavily
in the analysis of Seti PMS so Jordan
algebras came from some problem in the
foundations of quantum mechanics and
formally they can be defined as an
algebra satisfying these three axioms so
it's a non associative algebras which is
commutative which is power associative
and which is formally the else meaning
that if it's almost where to 0 each of
the terms has to be 0 so so Jordan one
domain and Bignell classified all finite
dimensional formally real Jordan
algebras into five families
so three of these families came from
from matrix algebra so some one of the
most important examples of Jordan
algebras is matrix algebra with the
product defined as XY plus PI X by 2 but
there were two other families and one of
them was the spin factor which which has
this rather strange Jordan product so
Jordan product here is is defined in
this equation so
so it is splitting the vector into one
coordinate and the rest and then the
first coordinate is the inner product of
the vectors and the second is a
symmetrized version of the rest and the
identity element for this operation is 1
0 N and it is this Jordan algebra that
will be heavily used in the analysis of
the SOC P into the point method
so this Jordan product is a linear
operation it in particular it has a
matrix representation so if I write the
Jordan product as a matrix I get these
Aero matrices so so it's a matrix which
has you on the columns on the first
column you on the first row and on the
diagonals so it's shaped like an arrow
so Jordan product u dot V can be written
as ro w arrow u times the vector V
and similarly black women can extend
these Jordan products block whites so if
I have a product of Laurence Kunz I can
define the Jordan product competent rice
and these belt structured arrow matrices
somehow make the linear systems that
arise in the interior point methods much
simpler like and the construction of the
corresponding block encodings for the
quantum material point method much
simpler than the SDP case let's see
so now so now I'll see something about
the interior point method and how you
analyze it in terms of these Jordan
algebra so the central part for the SOC
P and also for STP is an LPS is
parameterize by feasibility and
complimentary slackness conditions so
the first two conditions are feasibility
for the primal and the dual problems as
the last condition is a version of the
complementary slackness condition so it
can be written in terms of the jordan
product for the SOC p if i was writing
it for the FTPS it would simply be x
time says as matrix product is nu times
identity and the central part converges
towards the optimal solution as nu tends
to 0 so the complimentary slackness
conditions for primality say that X dot
s is 0 so the main idea for the interior
point method is to start with some value
of Nu and then find increments Delta X
Delta Y and Delta s so that the updated
solutions are close to the central path
for a small value of Nu prime and this
factor Sigma is like 1 minus 1 by square
root n or 1 minus 4 1 by square root R
for the socb case and that's why you
need a certain number of iterations for
this item to converge
so what are linear systems that one
needs to solve to make this iterative
improvement so so they obtain by
linearizing the last equation which was
given in terms of the Jordan product and
neglecting the quadratic term so if i
linearize it and neglect the quadratic
term i arrive at this newton system and
we can see that for the suc p this
system is rather simple like it just has
the input matrices na transpose and
these aroma traces which can be
constructed directly from the solutions
s annex that
and the analysis of the IPM in the
classical case shows that if X Y s is a
neighborhood is in the neighborhood of
the central path then the updated
solution remains in the neighborhood of
the central parts so the quantum IPM is
a bit different like we don't solve
these linear systems exactly but we
apply a quantum linear system solver and
then do tomography to recover
approximate solutions and therefore one
needs to give an approximate analysis
which shows the same statement with
respect to approximations
so so the basic idea for the quota my
team is simple like one uses the quantum
linear system solvers instead of the
classical linear system solvers and one
needs to write down the next system so
after having solved this linear system
when there's tomography to recover the
solution to the system and that's used
to construct the next linear system so
the main tools that go into the main
quantum tools that go into this are
quantum data structures which allow us
to do efficient unit free block
encodings for for the linear system
matrices and then bottom linear systems
always the state of the art is answer by
Chakravarthy helium Jeffery and more
recent work by Gillian and others so
given block encodings for the input
matrix quantum clean the system can be
solved in inverse case time square root
n kappa rockman of it's not kappa being
the condition number and then there is
this fast tomography procedure which we
developed for ftp interior point methods
and that says that the output of quantum
linear system solver can be
reconstructed in time log in awaits long
squared so the time is n log in awaits
long squared for l 2-norm guarantees
like the ones we use here to get X hat
minus X less than epsilon in x2 and log
in a bits long squared for the L
infinity guarantees so these are the
basic quantum tools that we'll be using
and and not delve too much into them
because it's already been talked about
so the analysis of the quantum interior
point methods for the SOC P is basically
done using this Jordan algebra switch is
also provides a unified analysis in the
classical setting for s BP's and SOC
Peas so so the interesting part is that
like like the spectral decomposition for
matrices one can have a spectral
decomposition using the Jordan algebra
where they're exactly two eigenvectors
and this applies to vectors in the
Lorenz cone so the god the Lawrence
Cohen serves as the cone of the vectors
which have all that in value is positive
and we can define analogs for all the
matrix quantities like the spectral norm
which is larger of the two eigenvalues
on the true beam
snob which is the sum of squares of the
two eigenvalues and we can even find
analogues to the familiar inequalities
like ex-wife opinion is less than
expected is why for being is
and similarly like for the analysis one
has to find analogues of all the matrix
quantities that one uses in this to be
analysis so so for example in the STP
analysis one uses matrix scaling Y goes
to X Y X and this has a Jordan algebra
analog of two arrows squared X minus our
x squared so by making this dictionary
one can translate the approximate ipm
analysis for the SDPs to the socb
sitting and get similar results
okay so now and talk about the
experiments and what kind of speed ups
one can hope to get out of these into
the point quantum eighty two point
methods ways to see peace so the
experiments we carried out for own
random STM instances so I'm going to
define what a random extreme instances
on this slide so so first we generate
the data points so we generate M of
these points from the unit hypercube
uniformly at random and then we generate
a random vector in RN which is supposed
to classify these points and the labels
assigned as weii as the sine of double
cross products I and we corrupt a fixed
fixed proportion of the labels so that
the dataset is not exactly classifiable
and shifted by a normal distribution and
we perform this experiment over a wide
range of values like this distribution
let's call it s vm n to NP let's fix em
to be linear in N and P is uniform from
0 to 1 in multiples of point 1 and n is
uniform in 2 to 2 to the 9 so so that's
the definition of random assumes we went
for this because we wanted to have an
unstructured data set where no algorithm
could be using some structure of the
data to get an advantage
so it depends on this fixed proportion P
that you are corrupting
so we so the first observation is that
you don't need to solve this OCD to very
high accuracy to get good classification
results so so even a modest position
like epsilon equal to 0.1 is good enough
to get high accuracy results with SVM
and that's good for the quantum
algorithm because when there's
tomography and incurs one of its long
square penalty for for the precision so
so the comparisons we made were with the
classical SOC be solved with the eCourse
and the lib SVM with a linear kernel so
we found that for these instances no on
the last slide the eCos solvers scales
empirically as in three point three one
four and this is modulus consistent with
using a splat scrat's and like matrix
multiplication algorithm it exponent 2.8
and the lib SVM skillset is better it's
in three point one one two it's
consistent with alternate approaches to
SVM like one doesn't have to solve the
SOC p2s beam there are the techniques
for it and then we look at the scaling
of this quantum running time which is n
square Kappa Delta squared and and we
find a 95% confidence interval in the
range two point five six two point six
two and also it's important to see that
the classification accuracy of the
quantum and classical algorithms are
very similar so this is a plot of the
classification accuracies on the
training and test sets so so the blue
and yellow lines are the ones which
compared it to the classical SOC P
solver so as we can see the accuracy is
very close for because they're basically
using the same algorithm and the red in
the purple lines are the months which
compare against the lab SVM
so the algorithm is different so we see
a wider gap but it's still quite
comparable in performance to the to the
classical algorithms in terms of
accuracy
so so the experiments that we can make
like it's also difficult task to
benchmark qml algorithms or quantum
optimization algorithms in de
yes so it's a graph of the empirical CDF
between the extreme accuracy differences
for the two algorithms
which is a classical
it's a difference between the quantum -
the classical accuracy difference so so
the ideal a plot would look like one
which goes to 0 and then rises to 1
so so we find some experimental support
an idea that the quantum IPM achieves a
polynomial speed-up for su cps with low
and medium crustation requirements and
so random instances it seems to get a
polynomial speed up with some exponent
and we obtain similar results for
another instance of the SU CP which is
the portfolio optimization problem so I
have a few slides on it if time permits
but but the results are very much
similar so it's not something radically
different and as a conclusion I'd like
to make it said quantum optimization
methods can achieve polynomial speed ups
for the longer term algorithms and no
and the main open question with regard
to quantum interior point methods is
it's what one can get if one replaces
the quantum tomography with the Vicker L
infinity norm guarantees so this would
speed the quantum algorithm up by quite
a lot but when needs to carry out
classical analysis to to establish such
method so there's some hope that this
might work because recent classical LP
algorithms do such kinds of analysis
so I would like to conclude there and
let's have time to go over the portfolio
optimization
[Applause]
so it looks like this cotton interpret
Method Man is right you can presume for
low and medium personal your sister
liked it for inter for the Masters it's
not so for the classical interior point
methods and the scaling and position is
logged when a bets alone but for the
quantum interior point methods we don't
solve the linear systems exactly the we
solve them only to low precision because
quantum tomography scales as 1 over
epsilon squared so that's usually if
you're up to services on boundary as you
running from interior points go to the
boundary the condition the matrix
becomes very very bad it's
[Music]
so that's maybe estimated these
condition numbers empirically for the
for the SPM problem for example and we
found that they were reasonably well
behaved like the scaling is not
arbitrarily bad it's only like one way
to learn bad
I'm wondering if you could compare some
of your work to some of the earlier
times because there were alternative
approaches that would it is of course
alternative multiplicative weights based
approach to quantum stp solving and and
the defender they depend on different
parameters but they're also in the low
accuracy regime like they have a epsilon
dependence which make them inapplicable
to very high precision I couldn't hear
the end of your sentence I was
interested so so the other methods are
using the matrix multiplicative AIT's
methods like we heard some of about some
of them on the previous talk and and
they have a strong epsilon dependence
has went like this scale has one wait
long squared or overs so this so they
are also not applicable to the high
precision regime
and they depend on different parameters
not in the condition number but on the
width of these multiplicative
any more questions thing to speaker ego
[Applause]